[Chill music]
- Ja!
- Hey, it’s Ja!
- Best out of his draft class!
- Oh, and Dillon Brooks!
- Man, I haven't seen Grit City this happy
since we switched Gasols.
- Hopefully I can be a good face
of the league for everyone.
[Siren buzzing]
[Townspeople panicking]
- What’s going on?
[Earth rumbling]
- Z...Zion!
- ROARRRR!
- [Dillon Brooks:] He’s got a new body.
[Evil laughing]
♪♪♪  Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Riaru-sa misetayo ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Born to be a legend ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Hikari o mezashite ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
- ROAR!
- [Townsperson:] Oh, no! A titan with clothes on! Run!
- ROARRR!
-[Ja to himself:] Why is everyone so excited about Zion?
He hasn't really done any-
- ROAR!
- Dillon, get the Gritizens to safety!
[Ja to himself:] According to the overly detailed
diagram in my head,
nothing can stop Zion once he gets
through the perimeter.
- Don't worry. There's strength in numbers.
[Zion evil laughing]
- I still remember your weakness.
[Zion groaning]
[Gasps]
Even his kicks have changed!
Time to get flashy.
[Zion groaning]
The Association! It’s controlling him!
- ROARRRRR!
- Zion! It’s not just you against me!
This is bigger than that.
Remember the code!
- [Young Ja:] Zion, let’s promise to always be best friends.
- [Young Zion:] Promise! Now let’s go destroy
some fellow children.
[Shoes malfunctioning]
- The...code...
Spoiler alert: I was in there the whole time.
Whew.
Thanks, bro. They really tried to pit us against each other.
- Those old heads stay controlling the narrative.
- We gotta fight back.
Follow me.
[Tense music]
- Once Ja and Zion take each other out,
nothing will be in our way.
- [Chuckling] Yeah, nothing.
[Steady footsteps]
- Are we sure we want to activate...him?
- The Association headquarters are in The Holly Woods.
So we attack them where it hurts.
[Machine-like sounds]
[Upbeat music]
- [Charles Barkley:] The rising young stars are finally
fighting the old heads.
They're even taking down some legends from
within their own ranks.
There's no doubt a new class of heroes has risen up.
And ain't no way LeBron and those bus riders
taking out them kids.
Take them out to dinner maybe.
- Look at you. Already talking about food.
- I know you not talking!
All you talk about is barbecue chicken!
- At least I got rings.
- Ahhhhh!